foreign
looks like we're now live uh for the AMA
it's a little bit before noon here in
Milwaukee but I've already got a lot of
questions lined up so I thought I'd
better get started on them especially
given that the first three sets of
questions are not
um
easy to you know answer in a very short
um discussion so the first one is a very
political question from Kyle JC how do
you think the upcoming trial of trump
and the insurrectionists will affect the
fascist movement in America
surreal that he probably has a
republican nomination despite everything
yeah so there's a couple things to say
first is that
um it is correct to talk about a fascist
movement in uh America right now because
you know if we if we think about it in
technical terms right Scholars of
fascism identify a number of core
characteristics of it and a lot of the
people on the right wing here in America
engaged in you know cultural politics
and politics and in general are in fact
they meet the Criterion of fascists and
I would say that
um you know the Maga movement is
essentially a fascist movement at this
point in time and it it's you know these
things have transformed you know at
point after point after Point any decent
person involved in there could have said
like whoa holy crap you're actually
going there
um you know I I'm not gonna go along
with that so you know great Point case
in point religious people that back
Trump who has just I mean a complete
scumbag you know abusive to to women
foul mouth cheating on wives just just a
scumbag in general cheats his business
partners uh leaves people behind it
bankrupt because of that any follower of
Christianity in any real traditional
robust sense would be like we can't be
involved with that scumbag but you
notice that uh people are willing to
compromise their principles in order to
do that which tells you what they're
really about it's not say Christianity
it's not the free market it's not even
like cultural conservativism it's more
like we want to have people to hate and
we want to have power and we want to
kill our opponents jail them sideline
them as much as possible there is a
fascist movement going on and so do they
identify themselves as fascists no and
there's a lot of like silliness about
the Nazis were actually on the left
which is complete nonsense you know from
a historic perspective
um or you know the left is fascist and I
know the left has got its problems but
right now the right in America is where
the core of the the most significant
problems lie and what is
um you know Trump uh eventually going to
prison and the January 6th uh Traders
conspirators uh getting a sentence going
to do I mean in some cases for some
people they're going to be like holy
crap you know this is madness I don't
know how I got involved in this but I'm
gonna I'm gonna go away and so you've
got some people who do that you know
great example here in in Wisconsin is
Charlie Sykes who is a never Trumper
um but you know he's Sykes is still a
racist and a misogynist and you know a
thoroughly bad guy he just happens to
like have drawn some lines
um and you find people like that every
once in a while but I I think for the
most part the the Maga people they've I
mean there's nothing that Trump can do
or say at this point in time that would
you know be the crossing the line for
them because they've managed to you know
think and feel and talk their way into
all sorts of crazy contradictory
positions I don't think that's going to
change so the only thing we can do is
kind of sideline them as much as
possible and that's why people like me
who I you know I've actually voted for
republicans and Democrats in the past I
register as an independent I probably
won't vote Republican the rest of my
life and I'll be voting against them and
there's many people like me that are
Independents that you know look at this
craziness and we're like well the
Democrats may not be great but this
party over here is just abyssimally
awful at this point in time I think
Trump will probably get the nomination
because none of the Republicans have the
guts to actually stand up against him
anymore except for you know impotent
ones like like Chris Christie and it's
funny because just you know blocks from
here you know about a year from now
we're gonna have the Republican National
Convention right over in the Fiserv
Forum uh here in Milwaukee so we'll see
what ends up happening all right let's
jump into galen's question
is from Galen bornster there's a bunch
of ways to teach intro to philosophy and
I'm only going to answer uh one of these
because I do want to get to everybody
else's questions there's a bunch of ways
to teach intro to philosophy what have
been some of the different ways you've
taught over the years and what caused
you to switch the way that you did it so
I've I've usually been unless it's
mandated for me I've been a text person
right meaning that I don't usually use a
textbook
but I like students to read original
sources
and I you know I've done it a couple
different ways I mean when I was
teaching at Indiana State Prison we did
have to use a textbook
um in part because you know our
resources were limited but I would
supplement it with
um lots of handouts and secondary
readings and stuff like that so you know
like for example when we were talking
about freedom and determinism I'd give
them a handout about you know Freedom
libertarian libertarianism uh
determinism compatibilism and then I'd
have them read a little Hume and a
little this and a little that you know
but when I wasn't teaching in situations
like that then I typically like to
assign actual you know texts or
selections of text so
I often do it in kind of a chronological
order I don't usually do the
pre-socratics unless I'm mandated to do
that
um in part because there's only so much
time in in a class so we usually start
with Plato and I typically start with
the apology because you know we get
Socrates and then you know we'll do some
other Socratic text depending on what
kind of class it is sometimes I I will
Orient an intro class around a
particular theme like I did one on
dialogue and dialectics I did one on
love and friendship
um but most of the time what I'm doing
is I'm introducing them to some key
thinkers and texts that I particularly
like and and think that they'll get some
benefit from and that I can you know
provide some good examples for their
everyday life uh from as as well so
that's
um you know that's how I typically
structure things and it seems to work
out okay we we never get to as much as I
would like to unfortunately but I mean
that is the problem with academic
classes in general isn't it that you you
never get to do as much as you'd like
and in an intro class
that's even more the case all right so
Ray says
um
do you think there's other intelligent
life in the universe
I would say trivially yes uh and I would
say it's in our little corner of the
universe because I'm willing to count uh
the you know some of the primates the
Apes that we share so much in common
with and cetaceans you know whales and
dolphins elephants uh octopi corvids you
know I I think that they're intelligent
uh I think that intelligence is is a
scale rather than an on off switch I
mean if you're asking me about aliens I
don't know you know that's not that's
not something that I have any views on
one way or the other
um
because I just don't have enough
information to to make a
well-informed
um
uh
inference we could say about that right
uh Mark and White Tower say hi uh from
from Greece and from South Africa good
to see both of you here
um
dacosaur what are your thoughts on the
Republican satanic panic over
transgender kids and transgender people
in general just existing I'm transgender
and it's scary to be honest yeah I mean
I think that this is uh sort of
unmitigated irrational hate and disgust
on their part that keeps on getting you
know whipped up by all of their news
sources and I think it's it's
essentially like a bunch of people who
like to get together to to bully and
hate other people and and uh it's a you
know there is a mind virus out there but
it's not a woke mind virus it's the
anti-walk Mind virus on the part of
conservatives who aren't conservative
anymore because they don't honor any of
their previous commitments to like you
know equality or caring about people or
any of the things that at one time made
conservativism uh a decent uh movement I
mean it's it's it is scary it and it's
gross and it's uh awful and we should be
trying to resist them uh at every step
of the way and asking them why are you
such screwed up people what the hell is
wrong with you you know so that's that's
my take on that the good news is I think
that the the Animus against transgender
people will probably I mean the the
conservatives go through fads right I
mean think back to a couple years ago
when it was post-modern Marxism that
they were all in a tizzy about and now
you don't see them saying anything about
that or black lives matter right I think
that
um they're gonna act like jerks but
they're like inconsistent jerks they've
they don't have much of an attention
span and we'll see what they're on to
being crazy about next year you know so
that's a silver lining to it uh or him
do you know of any way of utilitarian
thought to answer the questions of Duty
of what one is obligated to do as
opposed to Simply what's better or worse
than the utility scale
yeah I mean Reed Bentham he actually I
mean the word deontology is is the title
of one of his late Works uh the
utilitarian conception of Duty which
they talk about a lot
uh including at the beginning with
Bentham it happens to be what is most
likely to you know produce the best
effects right and so that is the
conception of Duty for for them and they
think that there are a lot of things
that you can say
um these are you know most often
producing the best effects therefore
these are your moral duties and then
when you get to people like John Stuart
Mill it gets even more robust
um I you know I think what you need to
do is actually go and read utilitarian
text rather than glosses on them because
you always want to know what the actual
thinkers have said and and mean all
right
um Jordan I was wondering what your
overall thoughts on hegel's philosophy
now that you're almost done with the
phenomenology of spirit series it hasn't
really changed I mean I got into the
series after spending you know about at
that point in time probably 15 years
reading Hegel you know teaching his
works and talking about it with other
people you know when I was in graduate
school
I first took a course covering the
phenomenology a graduate level course
and then helped to lead reading groups
on the phenomenology
and you know read through hegel's other
works as well and so it's not something
radically new I'd say you know spending
the time I do have a greater
appreciation for certain sections
um like you know the discussion of
morality I'm I'm I'd like to go back to
that and like unpack it a bit more
um if I ever have the time but I mean
some of the big things where I disagree
with Hegel I disagreed with him when I
started the half hour Hegel series like
obviously history didn't end you know I
think that he often is a little bit too
dismissive of uh the the stages that he
thinks we've essentially Left Behind
um you know I totally disagree with him
the remarks that he has in his uh
history of philosophy that we can't go
back and resuscitate uh ancient or you
know medieval or whatever philosophy
because the time has gone by
um so there you know there's quite a few
things where I I disagree with them on
but I I don't think that those have
changed through the
um
the work that I've been doing I think
they've just gotten more content you
could say right
all right
um
Fabian Vela in meditations Marcus
Aurelia says he was taught not to
frequent public schools and to have good
teachers at home and such a things a man
should spend liberally how does that
applier look today obviously it doesn't
apply today because uh Marcus Aurelius
what you know what he's calling public
schools are not what we call Public
Schools so you want to avoid
equivocation and the kind of mistake
that comes from like transplanting
things directly from a totally different
time and very different culture right
into our own I mean the thing that you
should think about is how do you find
good education in general and that could
happen through private schools that
could happen through hiring a tutor that
could happen through using resources on
the internet that could happen through
Public Schools it all depends so to me
that's kind of a you know good
cautionary Tale
you know um
you could say that public schools in the
sense that we think of them today
weren't really available until
widespread until you know the 19th
century
um
so you know Marcus isn't talking about
our own public schools and we can have
some great public schools and some
terrible ones here in Milwaukee you know
they run the gamut you know some of them
are very challenged and some of them are
quite good
all right uh prax says have you heard of
Louis Lavelle and Renee listen what do
you think of their philosophy heard of
them never actually read them so I don't
have anything to say about them as far
as I can remember I don't think I've
read them I mean maybe I encountered
them in graduate school but that was
that's going on uh 20 well it's more
than 20 years ago because I got my my
dissertation finished in 2002 so
all right Walter White can you please
recommend a book to start learning
philosophy assuming the learner is a
complete beginner
um I actually have an article out there
that you can easily Google and find you
know about 10 books to start with in
philosophy and why you should start with
those in particular
um so you know I I there is an a single
book to start with and you don't have to
be worried about like having the right
book because
um whatever you pick you're gonna have
to re-read it and you know sort of it'll
gain more meaning as you situate it in
with other texts that you're reading so
I mean the key is just to jump in I mean
I usually say start with Plato right and
um like I said I start students with
Plato's apology but there's so many
other things you could start with you
know you could start with Renee
Descartes meditations although that's
kind of a difficult work there are some
technical terms but I mean the good
thing is
there's so many resources now available
to help you understand these these texts
as you're studying them you know I've
got a whole I've got like at this point
in time close to 3 000 videos
um and I think I think I'm probably well
over a thousand core concept videos and
then there's all sorts of other people
out there doing similar work so you know
you've got lots of help whatever work
that you're going to start with
uh yora could you recommend some good
sources on applied ethics particularly
bioethics
um I mean here's where you could
actually get your hands on a textbook
because they all cover more or less the
same kinds of things right there's a
bunch of topics they introduce it to
moral theories
bioethicists tend to be much less
sanguine about utilitarianism although
interestingly you know the majority of
the decisions that are being made
in managing resources are are going to
be from utilitarian point of view
there's a lot of like classic articles
out there that we tend to teach in
bioethics classes you know when we talk
about abortion you're you're inevitably
going to have Judith Jarvis Thompson's a
defense of abortion about the violinist
and stuff like that but I mean there's a
whole bunch of uh things out there
there's no one like single source that
covers everything and and comes to mind
that way
um and and most of the Articles tend to
be
focused on like this particular issue
like in vitro fertilization or
implications of moving from a one one
understanding of what constitutes death
to another one like you know uh heart
um cessation to to brain death you know
um but I mean I don't have
recommendations about like which
particular articles you should read or
anything like that
all right
um
so Albert has some kind of snarky and
dumb stuff to say here the privilege of
acting scared of fascism in a country
like the U.S
what a dumb thing to say you know blue
team versus red team is kindergartner
level tribal nonsense I would say that's
kindergartner level analysis right there
so but you know nice that you outed
yourself
uh coal what does it mean when someone
says they're trained in analytic or
Continental philosophy
so that's a good question and by the way
I do want to say something here analytic
Continental philosophy just two of the
many different uh modalities and
traditions of philosophy there's also
classical American philosophy we have
all sorts of non-western traditions
going you know in massive cultural
spheres like the Islamic world uh you
know the East Asian cultural sphere
which you know includes China and Japan
Korea and Vietnam we have the South
Asian cultural sphere with Indian
philosophy and then all of its you know
further movements right there's
interaction and overlapping between
those we have history of philosophy we
have philosophy as a way of life so we
have a lot of different things going on
right but let's just talk about analytic
and Continental so
um analytic philosophy I think everybody
knows begins it roughly in the in the
late 19th century early 20th Century in
Britain with some extensions in the
United States and Canada early the
commonwealth countries and also you know
we have like the Vienna Circle as well
where in Vienna right
uh so we have some other thinkers who
are involved as well it's not just Brits
but it's largely a anglophone movement
although it has some you know it's
influenced Scandinavian philosophy
considerably as well and uh it's it's
kind of a reaction against not just
British egallianism but also against a
bunch of other things too you know some
of the analytic philosophers were kind
of bigots so you see like you know
um them railing against the Thomas
interestingly later on you get some some
Thomas in there like Anthony Kenny you
know who are an analytic but also you
know doing doing contemporary tomeism
and so to be trained in that you would
think would mean
learning the history and the early
writers and then learning some other
stuff interestingly most analytically
trained philosophers right now haven't
read their own history so they haven't
read G more you know they haven't read
uh much of Russell if they've read any
they haven't probably read much
Wittgenstein and analytic philosophers
tend not to read entire texts unless
they're very short you know are
considered seminal you know tends to be
more like articles and stuff like that
and it's it's a style you could say of
doing philosophy that tends to put a
premium on you know
um sort of like starting Anew with only
a limited literature not doing a lot of
examination of texts
um you know trying to focus on arguments
primarily and the analytic world is kind
of like you know spiraled into a bunch
of
um different
groups and they don't all communicate
well with each other anymore
um so you know we sometimes we talk
about a post-analytic phase and when I
say sometimes I mean over the last 30
years actually in analytic philosophy so
that is uh pretty crazy stuff
and then we have
Continental philosophy and Continental
philosophy you could say is less
unified I mean analytic philosophy isn't
unified itself but it's less so because
there's really big distinct traditions
in it like the you know uh Hegel and
Mark's access right dialectical
philosophy there's a psychoanalytic
access there's phenomenology there there
is you know a lot of uh Continental
thinkers who were in fact religious
think about certain Kierkegaard right
and we're going a little bit further
back too with Continental philosophy to
say the beginning of the 19th century
onward and Continental philosophy does
not Encompass everything that's going on
in Europe by the way it's more like what
what the Americans and Brits and others
made of what was happening in uh the
continent and what they were
particularly interested in and you know
you could say in general there's a
greater emphasis on like actually paying
attention to texts and language
that not relying so much on arguments
and the Continentals have their own
quirks that can be you know rather
annoying or hindering you know sometimes
there's a bit of preciosity and playing
around with words that goes on you know
assuming that you know
um a certain lineages are really
important
um so you know those are that's what it
means to be
trained in in these things and you've
been trained by other people who do that
kind of stuff
all right
um maximum I want to read the complete
work of Plato do you think I should read
early mid and late dialogues or do you
have another suggestion
I mean why do you want to read the
complete works of Plato to begin with I
would say start with that question don't
worry about complete at this point in
time worry about to start to read some
things and uh you know Plato anthologies
are generally arranged in what the
scholars think and you know there are
some things that we can say yeah this is
an early dialogue this is a late
dialogue like the laws we know that's
the last thing Plato wrote but there's a
lot of stuff in the Middle where we're
not really sure you know
um I wouldn't I wouldn't worry yourself
too much over that at this point what I
would worry about is actually like
reading the texts and then re-reading
them and understanding them and seeing
what other people who you think are
intelligent have to say about them and
you know realizing that you're not going
to like Master any of these texts but it
just you know just work through them and
see what's what's there
all right uh mojes how do you feel about
Thomas Nagel's opinion on death being
evil do you believe in the afterlife for
God I haven't read Thomas Nagel's
opinion on death being evil so I don't
have anything to really say about that
um
Tatton who's the best historian of
philosophy in your opinion cheers from
Chile there is no best
um there's just like you know people who
are up there and quite good
um but there isn't like a best it's not
like we give out trophies for this sort
of stuff or we all get together as
historians of philosophy and then vote
somebody in there there's a lot of great
historians of philosophy I mean think
about Friedrich hobblestone right I mean
and the Monumental work that he did way
back in his day that's great stuff right
but we also have people who have done
really awesome thematic work like you
know Christopher Gill or Julia Annis
um you know bringing together doing
comparative work Amelie Rory would be in
there I said Aleister McIntyre although
sometimes you know he does get people
wrong but uh so do all the best
historians uh Anthony long you know
um we could go on and on and on and on
there isn't there isn't a best for this
sort of thing
all right
um Abraham layer I've really enjoyed
studying Aristotle's Nick and McCain
ethics what would you suggest studying
next in the field of Ethics well if you
liked Aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics
you should read more Aristotle because
the nick of McCain ethics isn't the last
word on Aristotle's ethics if you want
to understand his overall ethical
perspective which also includes
philosophy of action and motivation then
you need to read the udamian ethics you
should also read the Magna moralia on
virtues and vices even though those are
probably not by Aristotle but our
Aristotelian you should read the
politics because that's where the nick
of McCain ethics ends doesn't it in book
10 we're now ready to move into this you
should obviously read the rhetoric which
talks about a lot of ethical issues you
should read the Poetics which talks
about character you should read the on
the soul and you should read book three
of the topics which deals with ethical
matters uh then now you've got a good
basis of Aristotle's ethics now was your
question like where you should go after
that I mean do you want to read other
big Heavy Hitters in the field of Ethics
then you know maybe read some Kant or
John Stuart Mill and Jeremy Bentham or
you know Friedrich Nietzsche or for that
matter you know go back to Plato because
Plato has a lot of interesting stuff to
say about ethics or you can read other
ancient philosophy that deals with
ethics like you could spend time with
the stoics who also have a very robust
ethical system or read somebody who
actually read all of these people like
Cicero you know and Compares and
contrasts them
or read things in the platonist
tradition like Plutarch you know who's a
middle platonist or alchemist's Handbook
of platonism or you know some of these
later as we call them neoplatonists
right there's all these different
Avenues you could you could go down but
there isn't um
I mean I would actually read more
Aristotle at this point in time
all right
um
captain of the nerd guard before they
went insane was there a single idea that
Republicans espouse that you agreed with
and why yeah I mean I've actually voted
Republican in some elections in the
course of my lifetime
you know I
um I was a fan of George Bush's uh
compassionate conservativism and
allowing a greater scope for uh uh
religious institutions and institutions
of Civil Society to provide help and
benefits to
um to those in need you know and you saw
um before he actually like went back to
his Iran stuff Paul Ryan was for that
that sort of thing
um you know guy from from Wisconsin was
speaker of the house at one time vice
presidential candidate of course Paul
Ryan has totally abandoned the
principles that he had I guess he didn't
really have any guts unfortunately
um you know I grew up in Waukesha County
which is often called the Republican
capital of the state of Wisconsin I I
volunteered in political campaigns for
Republicans who are friends of our
family
um you know the idea of like fiscal
responsibility and
um you know uh protecting the
environment which at one time was a
conservative idea you know uh
conservativism was also tied in with
conservation now now the Republicans are
all like the environment doesn't matter
exploit it as much as we can you know
just a couple examples of the going
crazy sort of stuff so yeah I mean the
the thing that's worst is that um people
who call themselves Republicans or
conservatives today
if you went back to like
um they would be kicked out of the party
as just horrible gross bigots by most of
the existing parties at the time so it's
radically changed you know all right uh
mojes uh what is the best argument
against an in support of veganism would
you consider going vegan for ethical
reasons I don't know I mean best there
aren't best arguments there are
arguments that people find convincing
um but you know no argument on its own
ever convinces anyone there's always got
to be some input that goes into that and
what I consider going vegan for ethical
reasons
um I I don't see the need to go vegan
veganism is very extreme and you know
that's why you see them uh arguing with
each other all the time and getting in
people's faces I think moving towards a
more plant-based diet is a realistic way
of doing things I think avoiding factory
farming is realistic I think that you
know like in our household
um we we don't really eat beef and pork
um you know and we're getting to the
point where we might we might not eat
chicken and turkey after a while
um in part because of the suffering and
intelligence of the animals we
definitely don't eat octopus you know
um but I don't I don't see the need to
like Embrace veganism uh with all of the
baggage that it tends to bring including
other vegans right
um so yeah all right Jordan I was
wondering if you think there's any
uh convincing strategy towards answering
the problem with a Criterion or
agrippa's trilemma some of purposed
visceral's phenomenological reduction
that's kind of like a a long way to go
for that
um I mean I don't take skepticism in any
sort of radical argumentative sense very
seriously myself
um
so it's not it's not that big of a a
deal for me right
um
I think that it's perfectly fine to have
uh
things that we take as axioms and maybe
not everybody else agrees with them or
they you know arguments could be made
because we have to live right
so that to me that's not that's sort of
a pseudo uh problem that's posed in the
uh issue of philosophy all right
um
Fatima says someone said Dairy does
understanding of difference defers
meaning of Disconnect or disconnects us
from a correspondence search for truth
or morality what would lone Dell say
about difference where he alive to to
read it
um I mean Darius says a lot of things
about difference and difference right
um and deferring meaning doesn't mean
that we never have any meaning it just
means we don't have an ultimate meaning
right here right now
um and it just doesn't disconnect us
from a search for truth or morality it
just means that we never have complete
Solutions right and Blondell would have
a zero problem with it one of the
earliest pieces I ever published is uh
from 2000 and it's about buried on
Blondell and how deconstruction the
method of imminence have a lot of things
in common with each other Blondell just
wouldn't uh agree with daried uh on some
of the things we're daried at is you
could say a little bit too dogmatic
right ruling out the possibility of of
things but you know later works right
where he turns back to religion and
politics and suddenly we can endorse
things uh although when we endorse them
we're never absolutely 100 sure that
we've got it completely right right
that's that's daried as position I would
say
uh milhan uh philosopher's corner do you
talk about philosophy with your family
um yeah with my kids when they're
interested in talking about
philosophical topics
um they're both very bright neither of
them are
um intending to study philosophy or you
know specialize in philosophy in its own
right
but you know cat is a theater major and
um very very interested in Shakespeare
and Shakespeare brings up philosophy and
quite a few plays so we get into
philosophical discussions you know most
recently over uh Aristotle's Poetics I
brought cat in to give a guest lecture
and my intro to Humanities class where
we're reading Sophocles Antigone and we
discussed Aristotle on that you know
um but you know cat doesn't have the
intention of becoming a philosopher and
Maddie
um I think probably wants to do
theoretical physics
so I mean that could change because she
is a junior year in high school right
now so
a lot could change in the next couple
years
but
um you know she's quite interested in
philosophy but not in studying it as a
discipline and then of course I have you
know my wife Andy and we both have a
strong interest in philosophy she's
actually still working on her
dissertation which is uh Martin
Heidegger is playing a very important
role in and you know we
run philosophy eats and uh we started a
branch of uh the Society of philosophers
in America here in Milwaukee and so you
know obviously we do talk about
philosophy quite a bit but we talk about
lots of other stuff too the day-to-day
thing of paying the bills what we want
to watch on TV uh with with my wife you
know uh local sports like the Packers or
our local hockey team the Milwaukee
Admirals talk about music with my wife
and kids so it's not all philosophy all
the time
all right
um
diagonia says have you ever read
symbolic exchange and death do you
consider baudryard to be a second-rate
thinker act just can't Envision uh you
getting much out of particularly
enjoying them for some reason I've read
a lot about yard back when I was in um
early years of graduate school and I
just never found them all that
convincing
you know
um I haven't gone back to reading him
for a long time maybe I would actually
enjoy him if I read him again but I mean
he's he's a typical French intellectual
very jargon heavy he's got his key
Concepts that he likes makes bombastic
claims you know just like Dairy died
Foucault did in their time
um
is he second rate
yeah probably you know I mean I wouldn't
go to beaudryard for like the keys to
the universe or anything but being
second rate is still pretty damn good
you know so I don't know I'd have to go
back and check him out it's been a long
time
um
all right Max uh
oh that's giving some advice
um
let's see what this is Benny I'm in
Luiz
um how do you understand who does
doesn't properly understand a
philosopher for example Nietzsche biases
that affect interpretation how to detect
this in secondary literature oh that's a
great question
I mean there's some easy tells right
like you've actually read The Thinker
and they talk about it and you're like
well that's clearly wrong because you
know they're attributing things to The
Thinker that I know are the Thinker says
the opposite of that or something
different than that
you know people who are sloppy and
overly schematic
you should distrust you know Nietzsche
is all about this no Nietzsche is a
writer who's got lots and lots of ideas
so anybody who tries to claim like for
example the key to Nietzsche's work is
the Eternal recurrence of the same well
they're full of crap you know that's not
true there isn't any key to Nietzsche's
work or if there is
if there's any one concept that's the
most important and it's the most
important among a whole bunch of them
it'd be the will to power right so you
know there's some easy tells
and then you know I would say you know
like you can you can tell this even with
like important thinkers like Hegel right
um You don't go to hegel's takes on
other philosophers for an accurate
reading of that particular philosopher
because you're just not going to get it
uh from from Hegel you're going to get
what he's interested in and very often
he distorts even though he's read the
the texts he distorts what's in the
texter you know reduces them down so the
stoics are just about this you know and
the epicureans are just about this and
you're like no no I mean
didn't you read this stuff yeah you did
read the stuff why are you saying this
sort of thing so if you actually know
the philosophers themselves you can do a
bit of comparing and when you tell
somebody's got like an ax to grind like
somebody who's a prime example this is
Iran right
um You Should Never Trust Ayn Rand when
it comes to any takes on the history of
philosophy not even for the people that
she likes like Aristotle because her
version of Aristotle is an Aristotle
right so when somebody's really
tendentious and they're like complaining
a lot or they're like praising somebody
else to the heavens like followers of
Thomas Aquinas can be really cool people
or they can be total ideologues and they
can be like Thomas Aquinas solved
everything and he did so on the basis of
his aristotelianism and you read their
stuff and you're like well they're not
getting Thomas right but they also
didn't get Aristotle right either
um what's going on here well it's a sign
of somebody who's
sort of misusing philosophy and maybe
that could be because of the way they
were taught or they weren't very
attentive readers you know so
all right uh let's see if we can get
some stuff there's a lot of people who
have already asked questions I'm going
to skip over those and maybe come back
to them if we have time and try to get
to some other people who haven't that's
their first question so can't read the
Cyrillic writing I should probably learn
how to pronounce Cyrillic terms
greetings from Belarus thanks a ton for
your lectures could you please recommend
some of your favorite 21st 20 20th 21st
century systematic fundamental Catholic
theology works I mean I don't do a lot
of work in fundamental theology it's not
not a
uh area of my specialization so I
wouldn't even know where to start uh
with that you know I I'm I'm reading if
I'm reading religious figures and more
often philosophers so I don't know I
don't actually have a good answer for
you on that uh Christian wow this is an
interesting one do you enjoy philosophy
more or less the more you age
um
I don't know that I enjoy it more but I
definitely don't enjoy it less
but I would say the enjoyment has
changed
it's
you know back when I was young and you
know I was reading philosophical
thinkers
uh like for the first or second time
like take Nietzsche for example right
you read nature and you're like holy
crap what is this this is amazing you
know and then you know you start to like
at certain points you're like well I
don't agree with about this but this is
really cool over here let me think this
thought with him right
um I mean that happened to me when I was
in in uh undergraduate and graduate
school I went through a nietzsion phase
um there's a certain like enjoyment and
pleasure and like the world looks
different as you're doing that
you know and then like a different sort
of pleasure reading Aristotle in the
Greek and seeing all these
interconnections between the texts as I
was mentioning earlier right uh if you
want to know Aristotle's ethics the nick
of McCain ethics is your starting point
and then you got to read the udamian
ethics and the two other ethical works
and the politics and the rhetoric and
the Poetics and parts of the topics and
the on the soul and there's other parts
as well and when you do that and you
start seeing all these interconnections
between them you're like whoa this is
cool it's still you know it's not fully
worked out but wow this is this is a
much grander Vista than I originally had
or when you finally read Descartes
meditations and get it like you can
appreciate even if you don't agree with
him you can appreciate what he's doing
there there's an enjoyment that that
comes with that right so can you have
that again after you been studying
things for I mean I've been studying
philosophy now
in systematic ways since 1990 when I
first went to college and became a
philosophy major so we're talking about
uh 23 years of my life I'm 53 now
um so
you know that 20 through 33 years right
1990 to 2023 so more than half of my
life you know I've been reading these
these people I don't know that you can
get yourself back to stage one and when
I read somebody new
um
I don't always get that I mean it
happens more often with like
uh literature that's philosophical like
when I got into Philip K dick and
started really reading his stuff
attentively about
[Music]
um
it was pretty amazing right I got a lot
of enjoyment out of that so I mean I'd
say I still get enjoyment but it's not
the same modality of enjoyment if that
makes sense
all right
um
Zach says
uh uh wanted to say professing is going
well I had one student ask if I taught
anything else already and I hope your
classes are coming along nicely oh good
yeah I'm glad to to read that a pyramid
how do you read books no recipe for that
I mean I've been reading since I was
three years old so I don't really know
how I read books
um I don't have specific you know ways
of doing it we all read books in
different ways I mean if you're looking
for advice about how to read
philosophical texts I've got a video
about that with pointers and there's
other people out there who have videos
or or you know blog posts as well but I
don't have like general advice also Isco
what is your personal philosophy these
days I I mean I'm an Eclectic so I bring
together
aspects of you know I would say the
three great virtue ethics uh systems of
Western Antiquity the plateness the
versatility in the stoic you know
there's later Christian authors that I
particularly like you know the
existentialists as well but I also
really like
eclectics like Cicero who I I greatly
admire and that's about I mean the
closest that I've got to a personal
philosophy I would say is a blend of
other people's philosophies I don't
actually think it's that important about
your own personal philosophy frankly
um I don't think you need to you know
reinvent wheels that other people
have out there available for you you
know
all right uh Jordan what do you think is
extremely interesting underrated let's
talk about school of philosophy in terms
of epistemology or metaphysics in
general so schools of philosophy I mean
I think that there's well there's a
massive interest in stoicism in a
popular way I think far too few people
actually read the actual stoic texts
which are quite interesting you know
um and I think that despite there being
some people who identify as
aristotelians uh there's not enough
reading of Aristotle's actual work
across the Corpus you know I think
there's a lot of great existentialist
thinkers that have kind of Fallen by the
wayside that were acknowledged as being
massively important in their time and
don't get a lot of reading these days
like Lev shustoff or Miguel de una Muno
um you know I think a lot of people
don't even read Albert Camus properly
you know they uh they stick to just
Mythic Sisyphus and the stranger and
they don't read the later novels and uh
the rebel and and you know letters to a
German friend and some of the other
important
essay is that that he wrote along the
way so I mean those are just some
examples
uh T what do you think about
similarities between stoicism and
Buddhism I think there are similarities
but I don't think that's that important
I think any
things you can find similarities the
question is well what are the
similarities mean that's the key
question and I think there's also some
massive dissimilarities obviously
Buddhism thinks you know in general I
mean there actually were some Buddhists
who who didn't agree with this as you
know what once you get into Buddhism you
realize it's it's a massive can of worms
the more you generalize about it
probably the more wrong you're going to
be because there's all these different
movements and schools and arguments
going on but let's say that the Orthodox
Buddhist position is that there is no
self
stoics think we have a self
that's a big dissimilarity right there
right
um
both you know think that there's there's
a ethical way to live they're not
completely in agreement about it but
there's a lot of similarities
um you know depending on what sort of
interpretation of stoicism we're looking
at whether it's classical or what we
nowadays call traditional or modern
stoicism there could be more or less
similarities about cosmology right so
but I I think it's kind of a
for me I find this a boring topic one
that's not worth spending a lot of time
on I don't know why people are always so
fascinated with it I mean does stoicism
become more true because Buddhists also
believes some of these things well they
also don't believe some of these things
right so by that logic that's not going
to help you
um and you know some of the things that
that stoics believe platonists also
believe like there are four virtues and
you should cultivate them right so I I I
don't find that very interesting myself
um
team again I just started my philosophy
PhD program any advice
yeah as a matter of fact I do have some
advice so it's going to sound kind of
weird
don't make the PHD program the thing
that you absolutely Center all of your
life around
you know make sure that you're attending
to your health both physical and mental
that you're getting exercise
um that you're doing other reading than
just the reading for your classes that
you're not getting sucked into the kind
of like uh esoteric terminology and
Prestige game that often is so common in
graduate school realize too that the way
that they're studying things or what
they consider important in your program
may not be reflective of what they think
in other programs you know
um
there's often this like well nobody's
studying this anymore and then you're
like yeah but they are studying that
right over there oh they they don't
matter we're the ones who count well
don't get sucked into those sorts of uh
sillinesses that that
people often indulge in
all right uh oh here's an interesting
question
um
from Marco what is your view on mass
tourism recently I visited some
historical places like Athens and Rome
and the enormous amount of tourists in
the Acropolis and Coliseum pretty much
ruined the experience
well
um
these are places that you know are
heavily dependent on tourism and people
want to see these things because they're
considered to be culturally important
you know like when you go to the Louvre
and you want to see uh the Mona Lisa
there's going to be a line and it's very
disappointing too you get there and it's
just like about this big you know uh
uh it's not it's not very
inspiring to to go to you know and um I
mean this is the case everywhere right
you go to Chicago and you go to
Millennium Park and you look at the bean
and it's all tourists all around but
what if you want to take a picture just
with only you in the picture and the
being well that ain't gonna happen
because
you're not the only person in the world
you know and you may understand the
cultural significance of say the
Acropolis and a lot of these other
people who are just snapping pictures
you know they're doing selfies with
their phone maybe they don't get it but
they're people too you know
so
um I mean what we want to do is make
sure nobody damages anything but I I
think with stuff like that or think
about other events like if you go to a
sporting event or a music festival
everybody else is there for that and
they may have very different
understandings like they don't follow
the team very well they've got a t-shirt
with the band but they don't know all
seven albums that they've put out but
you know they're people too and
they have a right to be there
just as you do and it sucks that it
ruined the experience for you but
it doesn't have to I mean I I think part
of the ruining the experience might be
dependent on what you assumed you were
going to get out of going there so maybe
it could be valuable for you to you know
think about that a bit you know
all right
um
oh it just jumped a little bit let's see
where we were
um
saxophone snowman well that's quite a
name I have seen and enjoyed your metal
takes on Twitter do you ever talk or
think about the connection uh between
metal and philosophy or the philosophy
of metal well as it so happens I have
inconsiderable detail
so I've got a publication and medium
called heavy metal philosopher right
which was sort of a uh reprise of the
blog that I started I don't know like
maybe close to 10 years ago called heavy
metal philosopher and you know I've
written quite a few articles about
things in the history of metal in the
philosophy of metal like you know the
problem of the ship of Theseus when does
a band cease to be a band you know when
all the players have been replaced and I
also
um
do a thing called heavy metal or classic
metal class with my friend Scott tiruli
I actually just put something out in all
my social media about this today I think
I think I didn't do it in YouTube though
um talking about the fact that Scott and
I we we had to take a break from it in
part because of uh personal stuff going
on his end and busyness on both of our
ends but you know we did 21 class
sessions uh over the years and you can
see them all in the channel
um and we're going to start doing new
ones in in November so yeah I mean
eventually what I'd like to do is write
a book about philosophical topics
applying to heavy metal matters like
can we actually say what the essence of
heavy metal is or is it something that's
a little bit more diffuse that way can
we say that there's an origin Point say
in Black Sabbath's album Black Sabbath
or is it more complicated than that what
is what is influence when bands
influence each other what is that
metaphysically right so these are all
things that we uh we get into and
discuss
um cool Jack any thoughts on zizak and
wondering if you recommend any of his
work I don't recommend his work I mean
or if I do I would say read the early
Zizek stuff before he started to like
become a star and sort of like Daria
kind of phone it in and just think that
whatever he wanted to blather on about
is somehow important I find him
unimpressive
um and I I think that if you want to
like people say oh I'm gonna study Zizek
so I can learn about lacan or Hegel
just read the Conor Hagel I mean you
don't need some intermediary who is like
all over the map all the time doing that
zizik in his Beginnings used to do
rather rigorous work you know but he
doesn't do that anymore now he's kind of
like you know just kind of like free
associating I think a lot of the time so
I I don't recommend his work unless you
know unless you're into that sort of
stuff but that's
um you know occasionally has interesting
insights but you got to Wade through a
lot of
a lot of stuff to to find the little
nuggets and I I just don't want to spend
the time on them
uh all right Max Montague I've I've
enjoyed your core concept videos on
Khan's groundwork uh I'm curious as to
how you first started reading his
ethical philosophy and what your
experience was of those beginnings
yeah that's a good question I don't
remember
when I first read him
um
I would assume
well no we we read the prologomina in
modern philosophy so it must have been
in graduate school
and
maybe I read it for the first time the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
by the way I highly recommend that you
when you read Khan's ethical philosophy
you don't just read the groundwork you
actually read the metaphysics of morals
which is an amazing work you know it's
broken down into the metaphysical
elements of virtue metaphysical elements
of justice and there's other ethical
works that you should read too obviously
the second critique some of the essays
and then religion within the limits of
reason alone if you want to understand
his full ethical system
um
I'm guessing I probably read const
groundwork
for my comprehensive exams as a master's
student
and
um
you know it was interesting but I I
didn't agree with him
um I don't agree with his theory of like
value and motivation to begin with and I
never have
but I I you know once you actually like
unlock the code and figure out what the
hell this guy is saying
like with Descartes meditations you
might not agree with it or hume's
treaties right but it's this very
interesting comprehensive system and you
can be like oh I see the I see the
structure of this this is pretty cool
you know
so but I I've come to appreciate kind of
more and more over the years
I teach them very frequently like every
ethics class that I teach we're covering
Kant
um understandably so because he's a
giant right and
um every once in a while I'll teach them
in other classes too so
all right uh Audi are any contemporary
interpretations of Foucault you'd
suggest I don't read secondary
literature on Foucault I just read
Foucault you know so I'm not I'm not a
good recommender for that unfortunately
and this is this is the case in a lot of
stuff you know I I don't read much
secondary lit unless I'm working on that
person so like I know a lot of secondary
lit for example on Anselm of Canterbury
but that's from you know
um reading stuff over the years and and
incorporating some of it into my own
writings
um
but for coal I I don't know and it's
kind of funny too because my my uh
Graduate School Mentor has a book on
Foucault which I've read but
um
that was years and years ago all right
uh Brock thoughts on David Foster
Wallace's Works does he fit into a
broader view of existentialism
I wouldn't say fits into a broader view
of existentialism I've never found him
impressive I I didn't you know people
hype them so much and I've only read a
few essays by him and I can see what
he's doing but I I just didn't find him
that that interesting so I'm not a not a
good person to ask about that probably
um
Andre says are you a religious person
what does it mean to you yeah I'm a
religious person
um
you know I it means that I wrestle with
God and I read other religious thinkers
and I'm interested in the ones for whom
religion and belief in God didn't like
solve all their problems but made their
lives more complicated and gave them
more to think about
um you know me and God aren't on the
best terms but we don't have to be right
um we each get to live our own life and
struggle with our own issues and
problems and uh I mean I will say that I
think that a lot of people who identify
as religious are actually full of crap
and lying to themselves and you know
down the line if there is an afterlife
there's going to be a lot of people who
say oh I was a Christian and then you
know like like the gospels say Jesus
will say yeah I don't recognize you
buddy you didn't do the stuff you were
supposed to do like you know clothe the
naked and uh console the the sorrowful
and you know all the things that are in
the teachings right because there's a
lot of people who are just fake
Christians out there now there's no a
lot of people who you know are fake in
other religions too
um it's part of their identity but it's
a it's a fake identity so
but you know that doesn't have to keep
you from caring about about religion
um lapse nine Continuum well here's an
interesting question
uh I have a hard time seeing the point
or utility of Lewis and Ian so David
Lewis style possible worlds am I missing
something what's your take on it so this
was like hot stuff when I was starting
graduate school in the 1990s
um David Lewis was a huge name there
were like whole you know books of essays
on possible World semantics and I've
seen a lot of people deploy it for
various purposes to try to think about
like philosophy religion or about
um philosophy of action and so the whole
idea behind this for those who don't
know David Lewis came up with something
that we we call possible worlds
semantics or cosmology the idea is that
we live in the actual world but there
are all sorts of other possible worlds
that are that are slightly different or
very different from our own world and
Lewis uh is assuming this
he has no proof for it
um but it but he assumes it because he
says this is a way that we can
understand
modal operators like
necessity possibility
impossible so the stuff that we talk
about in modal logic right
to say that something is necessary mean
that it means that it is the case in all
possible worlds to say that something is
possible means that it is the case in
some but not all possible worlds and to
say that something is impossible means
that it is not the case in any possible
world even though we can conceptualize
it and we can talk about it
so
is this useful
it's useful within that set of
assumptions and in certain fields of
analytic philosophy where they love this
stuff
um it tends to produce errors when we
say for example talk about possible
worlds in which God exists and possible
worlds in which God doesn't exist
treating God is just a being for example
and I've seen people do this at
conferences right uh and you're like
well
you know that's not going to work unless
you assume that God is just like a
maximally powerful being or something
like that
um so you got to make lots and lots and
lots of working assumptions that are
often
on
clarified in order to use the possible
World semantics
um I've never found it useful I found it
interesting but
um the people who have found it useful
tend to be
in in my experience they tend to be
close-minded to the very problems that
it it raises or produces so and I think
you know
more than 20 years in now since it's
heyday
I think there's less people using it and
talking about it right
um Mark uh Van Der boogard says will you
touch on lacan at some point yeah I've
got plans too but not anytime in the
near future
I would like to maybe go through
uh the seminar on the ethics of
psychoanalysis which I think is pretty
cool
um there's certain of the AKA that maybe
I'll do some core concept videos on but
I've got so many other things you know
like right now I'm doing a sequence on
Aristotle's Poetics for my classes and
then I've got a long awaited series on
kant's uh prologomina to any future
metaphysics and then I've got other
things that I'm going to do you know I
got to do some Thomas Aquinas stuff for
my classes this semester
um you know I've got lots of other
videos to shoot so you know
probably won't be doing any lacan stuff
anytime soon
uh Jordan what do you think about
skeptical theism as a response to the
problem of evil is it a good response
why are we not I I don't know what's
meant by skeptical theism that sounds
like something you know that they're
doing an analytic philosophy of religion
um and they've come up with some some
terms and I don't know what they refer
to
um I think that you know the problem of
evil is a genuine philosophical problem
and there's a number of different you
know ways of addressing it
um but I don't think that we try to
knock it down and say that it doesn't
matter I mean
you know dostoyevsky's
um uh discussions of it which don't
resolve it but but say it's a genuine
problem for example in Brothers
karamazov in the chapter called
Rebellion before the the grand
Inquisitor
um to me is is a great way of addressing
it you know
um I don't know that it's something that
we try to refute
uh razzmore do you have any humanism
videos
I'd say all my videos are humanistic
uh because I'm a human being and we're
studying human people and we're looking
at their their you know minds and stuff
that they have to offer I mean I don't
know what you mean by humanism videos so
all right black prairie uh how do I
become less systematic when it comes to
relationships it's hard for me to be
spontaneous
and usually just set end goals that are
unhelpful especially when it comes to
the opposite gender
I don't know
um
I I'm I think I'm missing something here
because I'm not sure what being
systematic in relationships
means to to you
um you've got like setting end goals
that are unhelpful and you're you're
contrasting that to spontaneity so it
seems like these are two end points but
there's probably a lot of stuff in
between I mean you could just like try
to hang out or go on dates or have
conversations that
where you suspend those end goals but
you don't necessarily have to be
spontaneous I mean you could actually
have like my goal is to get to know this
person better in a conversation because
I find them attractive and maybe down
the line I'll be involved with them it's
okay to have goals right and you could
even ask the other person what are your
goals
um
so I'm probably missing something there
all right let's see here
let's see if there's something I I
missed in a previous
question because I've got another
question that seems like it needs some
context
and I'm not I'm not seeing it
um
so sheilu says it's a bit like emotional
vulnerability in the process of grieving
death I feel stuck and scared been
reading writers and books to gain
strength and clarity
but in action I feel scared I mean
feeling scared isn't necessarily a bad
thing we feel scared all the time the
question is whether you feel scared like
beyond the reasonable measure of things
you know so for example I'm looking over
at some of our canned goods and you know
we've got beans and sauerkraut and
chickpeas and soup and corn and
it looks like we even might have some
canned potatoes over there I'm not sure
why we do and olives and mushrooms and
stuff like that and I could be scared
that any one of those cans might contain
bacteria that will kill me but that's an
unreasonable fear you know because I can
look at the can and see it's not you
know pushed out through botulism or
something like that
um we can distinguish between fears that
make sense and fears that are just
excessive and then there's techniques
that we can use to like analyze why
we're afraid
um but it doesn't you don't have to get
rid of all your fears as a matter of
fact The Fearless person like totally
Fearless is screwed up
um
but you know grieving dead people
um there's no like recipe about how
you're supposed to do that I I I I still
sometimes miss my parents and they've
been dead my dad has been dead since I
was 11 and my mother's been dead since I
was 29. you know uh there's other people
too as well my best friend who died when
I was in college
um
you know sometimes I'll think about him
and that's okay that that happens I
guess you know here you want to think
about proportionality and that sort of
matter right
um snoot I just finished the genealogy
of morals it got me really thinking
about the philosophy of Truth do you
have any interest or reading material
about truth in its nature yeah lots I
mean I've reviewed books about truth
I've uh taught you know for example
anselms on Truth or you know Heidegger's
notion of Truth is all if they uh
um there's there's quite a lot of stuff
out there in my work that that has been
done on Truth
um and you know it sounds like nature
thinks that everything is just all
falsity or BS but there's there are some
things that are definitely more true
than others for him
um alligator are there any existential
Works friendship
dealing with friendship or about
friendship yeah I mean there's there's
uh plenty of them because there's lots
of existential works that are poems or
stories right
um and then there's you know discussions
of friendship in existential writers
works I mean starting with Kierkegaard
um he he talks about it at different
points and also about love and
companionship and stuff like that so
yeah there's plenty of things out there
um
let's see here
uh uh Anthony says how has modern
science the advancement of science
motivated further work you've done in
philosophy in addition how does the
advancements also change how you see
philosophers you're most familiar
and science hasn't done much for me
because science doesn't have a lot to
say if it's real Sciences as opposed to
pseudoscience
uh doesn't have much to say about the
stuff that I'm particularly interested
in
um
science can't tell us whether we're free
or determined
science can't tell us the right way to
live
um science can't tell us whether there's
a God or not or you know which
understandings of it are are correct so
it hasn't done much for for me in those
respects
uh mohis have you read Allah Tom Perdue
and what do you think of it I didn't
care for Bruce much
um I found proust kind of boring frankly
and self-indulgent but you know
Different Strokes for different folks
there's a lot of prestige books that an
authors who I just don't get into
um but you should try it out right you
should at least like make a stab at it
like you know I'm also not into James
Joyce
um you know I read enough to be like
yeah not for me man I'm gonna I'm gonna
spend my time or waste my time on other
stuff that I think is more productive so
all right
[Music]
um
Jesus what are your views on the
existence of an objective moral standard
without a higher being or power I think
that there are objective moral standards
I also think there is a higher being or
power
um but I think that the people who say
that oh you know if there isn't a higher
being or power then I'll do anything I
want well that show just shows you that
they're bad people you know
um or you know people who project that
onto others saying if there isn't a God
then all morality falls apart they're
just full of crap those are bad people
that you should you know avoid and uh
not have anything to do with because
they're immature and clearly motivated
by bad impulses right
um Luca does Heidegger think anxiety
should be overcome okay so that's a good
question
anxiety in the sense that we talk about
it today is not the same thing as what
Heidegger terms anxiety or angst in his
his works it's not completely different
but a lot of people use anxiety just to
mean fear and Heidegger thinks that fear
is different than anxiety
um
and Heidegger thinks that anxiety is one
of the moods that is disclosive or
revealing of the human condition of the
you know the condition of dazine and the
world that we inhabit and its
metaphysical depths so should you try to
get rid of it all together no but there
are there are
um wrong-headed responses to it like if
you feel anxious and you just engage in
you know coping mechanisms all day long
about that Heidegger would say you're
actually you're kind of out of touch
with things and you're placing yourself
further out of touch with things you
want to understand your anxiety right
um
demand has an interesting proposal here
would you be willing to create your own
curriculum from bachelor's to PhD many
of us would be willing to pay you for it
and being serious we could make it
worthwhile
well so there's a couple things to say
first of all one person cannot do
graduate level work you need like a
whole department for that
so
you know if you see anybody out there
who's offering you a one-person taught
PhD you know they're full of crap so I
would never do that I could teach
graduate courses that could be part of a
larger curriculum but there's no way I
would I would do that and a PhD program
means you also write a dissertation
again you need like a whole committee
for that so let's put that aside could I
offer an entire undergraduate curriculum
I mean in theory yes
I mean when you say that uh
uh many of us would be willing to pay
you for it
uh the proof is in whether it's actually
happening how many people are actually
supporting me on patreon how many people
use the Super Chat function and when I
do events like this right to help
support my work
not that many
I mean I'm glad that some people do
right I have some some people who are
constant supporters but I would say 99
of the people out there who benefit from
my work
they might say a nice thing and a
comment but they never help support in
any any way
so you can say that many of us would be
willing to pay you for it but
they're not
so if if you know if I were to say oh
well
I'll put this whole curriculum together
because people will pay for it
well let's see him Pony up right I mean
I have online classes that I offer do
people purchase them or don't they uh do
people contribute in other ways I mean
sure I mean people some people will but
the majority of people don't so I I
don't know about that and I I have been
creating a whole curriculum right it's
just not a super organized at this point
in time
um but I have you know
now close to 3 000 videos
so and you know podcast episodes and
blog posts and actual online classes so
you know we'll see
um
all right let's see here
dritic is there anything in common in
Pan psychism and the stoic understanding
of nature so the classic stock
understanding not the modern stoic
understanding because a lot of modern
stoics don't think that there is some
sort of you know vast mind governing the
cosmos or anything like that
so the stoics like
the other virtue ethicists in ancient
philosophy and this went into Christian
philosophy as well
believed in something that we call the
degrees of being
and we know this from you know Cicero's
on the nature of the Gods
so you know there's there's God at the
top whatever God is and then there's
rational being and obviously God is part
of rational being but there's rational
beings like us
and then there's the other animals and
then there is the plants and then there
is bare being
unanimate being and inanimate being
doesn't have any Consciousness at all
for the stomachs
um whereas for a pan psychic it would
right
um this coffee cup could have some
Consciousness not obviously the
Consciousness that I have or even that
of an animal but some so there's a big
difference right off the bat I mean the
stoics would be willing to say that
plants have some things going on but do
they have do they have uh any sort of
Consciousness
you know hard to say right
so
[Music]
um
all right Charlie singer says uh I've
watched your videos for a couple years
but an action feels secure check out the
demystifying Discord you'd be a great
voicer I don't bother with uh Discord
um or you know other things I've already
got enough going on with YouTube
uh the four forms of social media that I
use which are Twitter uh Facebook
LinkedIn and Mastodon and then the other
platforms that I have so you know
limited time
um we don't all have to do everything
uh Ken oh hey nice to see you here and
uh you'll be happy to know that Scott
and I are talking about
um uh
getting the classes started I I still
would like to interview you sometime
about the new wave of British heavy
metal and what it was like being on the
ground there in Britain when it was uh
going on do I have a favorite Raven
album
um
that's a good question uh
uh I mean I really like the early like
the the beginning level stuff
but they've been making good stuff
throughout the years
and I actually was part of the I
supported the kickstarter project again
you know like if you actually like
people support them uh when they brought
out the extermination album which I
really really liked
[Music]
um
rock city is pretty good too and I think
Scott and I are probably going to do a
review of that down the line
um but it's hard to say and I've only
I've only seen them in concert once
um unfortunately
all right oh here is a interesting
question
um
what is the best part of Wisconsin
I don't know that there's a best part
but I'll tell you I love living here in
Milwaukee we have a city that's got a
lot of challenges
um but it's a great City to be in we've
got a food scene that is like drawing
International attention we have some
great Institutes of learning lots of
cool events going on uh
Amazing Music Scene you know with all
sorts of artists coming in in places and
not just you know rock and Pop I mean we
also have the world's largest Music
Festival every year at Summerfest but we
also have a great just an amazing like
out of out punching above their weight
Symphony Orchestra here in a new Hall
um so I love this but there's other
parts of Wisconsin that I really love
too like you know you've seen my
pictures from lap and Peak State Park
where I grew up just recently we visited
the big cat sanctuary uh out past
Madison near the Wisconsin Dells you
know there's all sorts of great parts of
this this state so
all right
um
let's see
Cornelius says uh in the previous AMA
who said you're not into young and
youngins do you feel that way towards
early psychology as a whole I don't if
not who are some authors you think are
worth reading I mean Freud and a lot of
the other freudians I enjoy reading I
just I'm not into young you know
um and there's there's other
psychologists as well you know Freud
think about William James right there's
all sorts of people doing interesting
psychology around the same time
um can you explain more what you don't
like in the writing of Jung besides the
cult aspect of his followers is his over
spirituality and mysticism or something
else so like I said I like reading Young
when he's actually talking about other
people because very often he's quite
interesting and incisive when he's
developing his own Theory I just I don't
buy into it you know and yeah the
followers of Jung are pretty cult-like
and they seem to like swallow everything
that he says and they all you know
they're kind of new Ag and stuff like
that not to say that you couldn't do
anything uh interesting with them but
it's just kind of a waste of my time you
know so
uh Charlie singer do you do interviews
I've done lots of interviews uh I mean I
I've probably done at this point you
know several hundred radio
podcasts video channel interviews I post
about them regularly on social media
when I do them I also interview other
people that's the ideas that matter uh
videos right
um
let's see
let's move on a little bit more
um
Tiny Titans says there's a philosophical
question I've been thinking of is there
a way to deduce the underlying nature of
a person to be able to look past
behavior in the outside while Behavior
reveals what's inside right so like
Thomas Aquinas says you can't even tell
whether a person is is rational by
looking inside their head you have to
deduce that from exterior signs and
that's as good as it gets there's no
like you know x-ray machine that lets
you look inside and see a person's ideas
but you see what they say you see what
they do you watch their behaviors over
time and yeah you can figure people out
you can tell when somebody's
bullshitting you you can tell when
somebody's genuine you could be wrong
about those things but you get better
and better at that over time if you
actually pay attention and don't make
everything be about your own past
history and your own fears and desires
and stuff like that so yeah
uh Hector says uh I'm I'm currently
starting my masters in philosophy what's
your take on Richard rorty I've been
considering building my thesis around
his philosophy well you know I I'm not a
fan of Rory myself I think that he's
kind of uh interesting at points but
kind of superficial he was a big deal
when I was in graduate school but I I
never found his his works all that
plausible or interesting there's lots
and lots of holes but that I mean you
could also do sort of a critical
assessment of Richard rorty right
um
and you know he's he's an important
figure in 20th and early 21st century
philosophy so why not do a master's
thesis on him I mean I did a master's
thesis on husful I'm not a hostrolian
you know
um
so you know and I was originally going
to do my my PhD on my dissertation on uh
Hegel and Blondell and I ended up just
writing on Blondell you know uh years
later I came back to Hegel so you know
it's perfectly fine to to do that
um let's see
[Music]
gonna have to wrap up pretty soon but uh
let's take a few more
um
so
Jonathan Johnson says I just started my
PhD in Arabic literature here in Oslo
do you have any general advice for
staying sane as a PhD student basically
the stuff I said earlier realize that
your PhD is important right you do have
to make progress on it but your life is
also important and your life is not
something that should get sucked totally
into the PHD maintain your friendships
with your friends who aren't all PhD
students maintain your connections with
your family make sure to get exercise
eat uh healthy meals you know take care
of your body because after the PHD is
done you're still going to have that
body right even uh when you're finished
with that that activity so that can be
quite helpful
um
let's see who we haven't uh answered
stuff from uh Thomas Diaz why is
happiness not the same as the good who
says that it isn't some people say that
it is some people say that it isn't you
got to take a particular point of view
and ask about that and then you can you
can get to it
um
[Music]
for hid says I came across your video on
depression the other night and found it
in a great catharsis I just want to
express the meaningfulness of your work
as it's helped me through the years
especially your gregarious nature in
general positivity oh well that I'm
really uh glad that that's been helpful
for you that was part of the the
um
that was one of the motivations in
putting out the video I thought it could
be useful for other people who suffer
from depression
um I mean one of the things to say is
you know when you feel depressed you
often feel like you're totally on your
own with it and you're not you know lots
of other people suffer from it including
um you know big name
philosophers uh I don't mean myself I
mean other people who I've known who are
like genuinely big names in the the
field
um in in conversations we've talked
about depression so you know it's it's
good to have a kind of we're not all
alone We're In It Together uh sort of
thing
um so I'm happy that that that worked
out for you
um
mohis says what do you think of the new
atheists Like Richard Dock and Sam
Harris Christopher Hitchens Daniel
Dennett I I don't take them very
seriously I think the at best what they
do is replicate uh the older atheism of
you know the 19th century the stuff they
have to say isn't very interesting or
new or original uh even though it is to
them in part because they're often not
very well read unfortunately except
maybe Hitchens
um
and it's interesting to see the splits
that have arose that have arisen
erosia in The Atheist movement as it you
know it broke into left and right right
wings of it including here in Milwaukee
the Milwaukee mythicist group uh uh you
know was at one time kind of a wide
range uh and those guys were writing at
a time when it was kind of a wide range
and a lot of them have taken kind of a
hard right turn you know which is uh
clear sign of irrationality on their
part you know they're not really uh as
philosophical as they they would like to
think they are all right let's see what
else we can
uh look at Joseph Clark thoughts on
David Bentley heart don't really have uh
many thoughts on him other than he's a
unusual Orthodox in that he actually
takes Anselm seriously as people should
and doesn't just give in to age-old uh
Prejudice and talking points but I I
don't read much of his work uh I have to
say he's not somebody who's often on my
radar
um okay so here's a great question to go
out
nickapharma Morton
um do you think one can combine having a
nine to five and getting into philosophy
more seriously I'm excited about reading
philosophy but I heart finding hard to
systematize because the job takes up
most of my mental space
so
um yeah you can do that I mean I I did
it as uh somebody
in between undergrad and graduate school
with learning languages and studying
philosophy while I was working uh not a
nine to five but a 11 to 7 30 third
shift security job right here in
Milwaukee and also working in the
morning and the evening as a barista
sometimes for weeks on end without
breaks you know but it takes a lot of
determination to do it it's it's harder
right it's not like being in grad school
where you can just kind of like
um take it easy and I mean you're not
taking it easy but you don't have all
these other pressures on you but it's
possible
um I wouldn't worry about being
systematic
there's lots of different ways to read
your way in philosophy and there's no
one single right way to do it
um I would worry more about like are you
getting something out of reading the
text and thinkers that you're you're
studying and are you able to
um discuss them with other people if you
want to I mean fortunately now with the
internet
there's so many other opportunities that
didn't exist back in the day right so
um that might be uh uh quite quite
useful for you to do
um you know
when your job does take up a lot of your
mental space you don't have as much
space for philosophy
um but there's nothing that says that
you have to be doing it at the same
level all the time as somebody who is
fortunate enough not to have to work for
a living but I mean Spinoza look at him
he was a lens grinder right that's how
he supported his studies and and work
um
Clancy's uh the the you know second
skolarc of the stoic school was a boxer
at first and then carried water for
people's Gardens that's manual labor
there's all sorts of possibilities and
and models out there and you don't have
to do everything you know you don't have
to place a lot of pressure on yourself
just try to make some progress right
so I think that's a good one to go out
on thanks Mark uh what's for supper
um leftovers actually uh which I've been
eating for the last two days for supper
we do a lot of batch cooking here in the
Sadler shock a household and my my wife
made a couple dishes a couple days ago
that we've been eating on for a while
and maybe we'll have something new I
think she she said something about
making some stew later this weekend uh
but but that that's yet to come so all
right well that is it for today I got to
do another thing in about a little less
than half an hour and uh a lot of other
things I got to take care of today
so thanks for all the questions and uh I
will see you down the line I got a
couple other things lined up this month
world's a speculative fiction we're
doing Thomas lagoti uh uh that's I think
next weekend and then we have the
understanding anger 2.0 we'll be looking
at echelis and so we've got a lot of
other great things coming down the pike
watch for some Aristotle videos on the
Poetics that I've been shooting and I'll
be releasing pretty soon and we've got a
lot of other cool stuff happening down
the line so I'll see you later